[Musique]
la prise de parole en public
ces mecs g16 inouïe d'une fuite m'a
tendu vers la catharsis fantasmes et
pour lequel l'allégorie onirique ne
reflète rien d'autre qu'une esthétique
confuse et demeter rien d'autre qu'une
sceptiques confuse et pellet père
fabrice luchini fabrice luchini on est
d'accord pour dire que fabrice luchini
il est capable de rendre n'importe quel
sujet intéressant et vous savez pourquoi
parce qu'il n'y a pas de sujet
inintéressant il n'y a que des orateurs
qui n'ont pas les clefs pour rendre leur
sujet intéressant ça c'est dommage parce
que prendre la parole en public c'est se
donner la chance d'être écouté et
réécouté c'est se donner la chance
d'être entendu être entendu de se donner
la chance d'avoir de l'impact alors moi
ce soir j'ai envie de vous donner deux
clés pour mieux réussir vos prises de
parole en public et donc pour avoir plus
d'impact
ces deux clés c'est la première enfilez
votre masque d'orateur et la deuxième la
confiance en soi ça se conquiert
alors enfilez votre masque d'orateur ça
veut dire qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire alors on est bien d'accord
qu'on parle d'un masque métaphorique on
est d'accord
et qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire de masse prenons l'exemple de
jean pierre bacri en perdre à cri ou et
tout ce qui c'est il a un personnage
public c'est le personnage du bougon du
râleur jamais content jean pierre bacri
ses personnages c'est comme ça
mais je ne dis pas que c'est que c'est
pas bien ce que tu fais si on fait ce
pas bien en fait c'est pâques c'est pas
bien c'est ce que ce que c'est nul
en fait ce que tu fais c'est ça le
personnage de jean pierre bacri on le
reconnaît mais jean pierre bacri on
imagine bien tu peux pas être comme ça
dans la vie de tous les jours parce que
sinon il y aurait personne qui voudrait
jamais vu parler
il vivrait avec personne ne l'aurait pas
d'amis même pas de chien est en fait
jean pierre bacri pourquoi est ce qu'il
est comme ça quand on voit à l'écran
c'est parce qu'il enfile un masque
ça veut dire que quand jean pierre bacri
tourner un film
peut-être qu'avant qu'on dise moteur est
là tranquillement en train de faire des
blagues avec les autres et là qu'est ce
que dit un chat quand ils rentrent dans
une pharmacie
il dit ce que je peux avoir du sirop
pour la toux
mais alors bon c'est une blague qui
n'est pas forcément très drôle entre
adultes raconte elle à vos enfants en
général ça m'a donc il est comme ça
tranquille et tout est là il ya le
réalisateur qui dit moteur et là jean
pierre bacri enfile son masque qui passe
deux actions mais arrête de te bats
c'est comme ça ça m'énerve un peu ça ça
m'énerve tellement que ça que ça que ça
m'agace d'être énervé comme ça tiens
voilà c'est ça le masque de jean pierre
bacri jean pierre bacri il enfile son
masque quand il se met en action
ça tombe bien c'est le mot qu'on emploie
au cinéma action alors vous évidemment
votre masque c'est pas le masque de jean
pierre bacri c'est pas le bougon c'est
pas l'heure à leur nom votre masque à
vous quand vous prenez la parole en
public
ça doit être le masque de l'
enthousiasme ça doit être le masque de
la passion et même si ce n'est pas votre
nature profonde n'est pas vous trahir
d'enfiler ce masque de l'enthousiasmé de
la passion et la chanteuse chris de
christine and the queen j'entendais
récemment en interview sur france inter
et elle disait le personnage de scène
c'est soi mais c'est le soin
choisis et ça nous permet d'être encore
plus soi même parce qu'on a choisi donc
à vous de choisir consciemment d'enfiler
le masque de la connexion le masque du
partage est alors pour ça moi j'ai
quelques petits trucs la première chose
pour enfiler le masque de la connexion
pour enfiler le masque du partage c'est
le sourire
moi j'ai un truc infaillible pour
sourire avant de prendre la parole quand
je suis en coulisses
hop je commence à sourire comment je
fais eh bien je pense à mes enfants
alors mes enfants ils sont mignons ils
ont 7 ans et 9 ans ils sont adorables
je les aime de tout mon coeur et du coup
quand je pense à eux ça me fait sourire
bon si vos enfants sont adolescents là
dans ce cas là vous pouvez penser à
quelqu'un d'autre je sais pas votre
conjoint votre conjointe pour ça marche
pas forcément non plus donc vous pouvez
penser à quelque chose que vous aimez
particulièrement comme un gâteau au
chocolat ou un mojito enfin découvert
c'est vraiment ça fait sourire gâteau au
chocolat
donc ça c'est la première clé enfilez
votre masque de l'intérim et des fois
une fois qu'on a enfilé ses masques
d'orateur et qu'on a souri eh bien on
n'arrive pas à le prolonger ce masque
d'orateur on n'arrive pas à le faire
continuer dans le temps et appareils de
nos trucs infaillibles
il m'arrive quand on aime une formation
prise de parole en public d'avoir
quelqu'un comme ça qu'a du mal à être
enthousiaste dynamique quelqu'un qui va
faire on va l'appeler bertrand par
exemple dont bertrand 80 d'être un peu
comme ça bon bah moi je suis ingénieur
en informatique
donc mon métier c'est de traduire en
ligne de code des cahiers des charges
alors j'ai rien contre les ingénieurs en
informatique j'ai moi-même été ingénieur
en informatique mais je suis repenti
donc quand j'ai bertrand quai comme ça
qui me manque d'enthousiasmé dynamisme
je lui dit bertrand bertrand tu vois ce
que c'est qu'un prédicateur à
l'américaine vous voyez ce que c'est
qu'un prédicateur à l'américaine un
prédicateur à l'américaine c'est un gars
il arrivait il fait un blu ray au corps
alors par contre évidemment quand le
prédicateur à l'américaine il à ce
nouveau d'enthousiastes rila ce niveau
de dynamisme le public lui aussi il est
à ce niveau d'enthousiasmé et de
dynamisme
le public il est là il est en mode
alléluia mn iasi et white donc je compte
sur vous je refais le prédicateur à
l'américaine il est comme ça allait me
leur welcome
[Applaudissements]
pire ils s'aiment everything au saut et
beckum en mai et fièvre 10h20 alléluia
vous avez compris vous avez compris
donc moi je dis à perdre en jeu face au
skate cela à coire et le diabète tran tu
vas faire le prédicateur à l'américaine
à bertrand a même fait un bon thé sur i
way écoute essaye il ya antique mais
essaye donc à bertrand y va bertrand on
y va et il a l'impression de faire ça je
suis ingénieur en informatique
mon métier c'est de traduire en ligne de
code
décaillet et chats
oakmont berton et à l'impression de
faire ça mais comme il par delà et qu'il
a l'impression d'arriver là en vrai il
arrive là et il fait je suis ingénieur
en informatique
mon métier c'est de traduire en ligne de
code des cahiers des charges et du coup
c'est parfaitement approprié pour une
prise de parole en public parce qu'il a
enfilé ce masque du prédicateur
l'américaine c'est ce qu'on dit parfois
en anglais quand on dit wait and see you
make a wave et la page aussi dire que ça
en fait fake est un petit remake et ça
veut dire faites semblant jusqu'à ce que
ça arrive vraiment quand on fait
semblant et ben ça finit par arriver
vraiment c'est ce qui arriva et bertrand
donc ça c'était la première clé enfilez
votre masque d'orateur et puis on a
notre deuxième clé la confiance en soi
ça se conquiert pas ce que vous en avez
peut-être pas conscience mais vous tous
nous tous on a 2 13 heures c'est votre
voix et votre corps
ça ce sont deux trésors qui sont très
très précieux et la première chose à
faire avec votre voix c'est de la
projeter projeter la voie alors ça peut
sembler un peu technique cette histoire
de proches de la voix mais en fait vous
allez comprendre ma prendre des exemples
de chanteurs alain souchon et johnny
hallyday alain souchon alors maman
bonbons
maman comment tu m'as fait je suis pas
beau allô maman bobo à long moment
[Musique]
johnny hallyday allait à toute la
musique que j'aime à toute la musique
que j'aime radu à toute la musique que
j'aime c'est la musique que j'aime bien
de la rivière du loup alors entre alain
souchon et johnny hallyday lesquels des
deux à la fois projeté
c'est john et bien sûr donc si vous avez
du mal à profiter vos devoirs penser à
johnny hallyday vous allez voir vous
allez bien donc ça c'est la première
chose avec la voit bien la projeter et
puis aussi ce truc qui arrive souvent
quand on parle ce sont les e vous savez
ce type de langage infernal le e
ces gens qui parlent et qui font donc je
viens vous parler de la prise de parole
en public alors bon effectivement comme
vous avez constaté que je fais des oeufs
vous êtes peut-être un décompte est de
voir que sa propre âme à noter en plus
j'arrive de mourir debout alors c'est
eux
ses tics de langage il est essentiel de
les remplacer par des silences le
silence un pouvoir monstrueux en fait de
parole en public
et là on peut s'inspirer aussi de
quelqu'un c'est un grand philosophe
belge jean claude van damme
jean claude van damme c'est le champion
du monde des silences jean claude van
damme il a rêvé qu'il va vous faire il
ya des gens
s'ils font pas à cette silence alors que
le silence là trois fonctions first
observatoire au trapèze que tu dois dire
après ces cultes et sert au public pour
comprendre ce que tu as dit à jean et
ford et sera resté away champion du
monde des silences jean claude van damme
c'est comme le client dès fois il part
dans les trucs qu'on ne comprend pas
mais alors on reste accroché à ce qu'ils
racontent champion du monde des silences
d'ailleurs victor hugo disait à victor
hugo disait la plus grande forme
d'autorité c'est le silence
on se dit en écho qui l'a dit donc on le
croit on l'a dit de trésors votre voix
votre corps votre corps way votre corps
voilà c'est un peu quand le prédicateur
à l'américaine il m'arrive parfois dans
une formation de gilles de parole en
public d'avoir quelqu'un qui a du mal à
occuper l'espace à utiliser son corps
pour occuper l'espace
on va dire elle s'appelle sophie sophie
elle occupe pas l'espace avec son corps
et la sophie 1 m 60 44 kg toute fille je
lui ai dit sophie tu vois gérard
depardieu
le film fait oui j'arrive à imaginer que
les gérard depardieu alors gérard
depardieu 4 mètres de large 6 mètres de
haut et 100 87 kg quand il parle on le
voit à 20 km quand il parle on entend à
10km bref sophie j'imagine que tu es
gérard depardieu sophie a fêté sur wii
je suis pas vu bertrand
bon bah voilà paraît donc sophie imagine
qu'elle et gérard depardieu
parce que au départ et des comme ça dit
des trucs du genre moi je suis
contrôleur de gestion
mon métier de l'établir des tableaux de
bord et de faire des budgets l'occupa
c'est l'espace et quand on imagine que
les jarres depardieu ça deviens moi je
suis contrôleur de gestion
mon métier c'est d'établir des tableaux
de bord il veut faire des budgets
et c'est fait et c'est la même chose
comme elle partait de là et qu'elle a
pense arriver là gérard depardieu en
fête a été quelque chose de parfaitement
approprié elle occupe bien l'espace elle
fait mon métier c'est contrôleur de
gestion
donc j'ai établi des tableaux de bord et
je fais des budgets et elle occupe bien
l'espace et en fait quand elle fait ça
elle visualise jarre depardieu quand
elle fait comme jardin par dieu quand
elle les mythes gérard depardieu elle
visualise gérard depardieu et en visuel
visualisant gérard depardieu
elle reproduit les attitudes physiques
et les attitudes vocal de gérard
depardieu est comme ça elle ressent les
sensations qu'elle attribue elle à
gérard depardieu donc les sensations
qu'on attribue à gérard depardieu c'est
le charisme c'est la présence et la
capacité en et les foules et pareil
c'est fake it until you make est elle
fait ça elle fait ça elle fait ça elle
finit par ressentir la même chose que
j'ai encore expérimenté hier en
formation ça c'est un truc incroyable
votre corps et votre voix sont des
trésors extraordinaire donc on a vu ces
deux clés qui sont les deux clés à
retenir d'abord enfilez votre masque
d'orateur et ensuite la confiance en soi
ça va se chercher ça va se conquérir
alors vous vous n'êtes certainement pas
imitateurs non
donc certainement il ya des chances que
vous ne fassiez pas fabrice luchini jean
pierre bacri jean claude van damme ou
gérard depardieu aussi bien que moi mais
c'est pas grave parce que je suis pas
venu vous donner un cours d'imitation
c'était pas du tout le but ce que je
suis venu c'est vous apporter quelque
chose d'essentiel
c'est que en prise de parole en public
comme dans tous les domaines il est
essentiel de s'inspirer des meilleures
de les imiter parce que en imitant les
meilleurs voux finirait par adopter
certaines de leurs attitudes
vous intégrerez ça et puis ça deviendra
des automatismes et comme ça deviendra
des automatismes ce sera vous finalement
c'est en imitant des meilleurs que vous
deviendrez vous même merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]